[Music]
we've been in this studio now doing this
new show for about three months and
we're having a great time we really we
love the space that we're in they
designed a very gorgeous beautiful set
as you can see but we noticed one thing
and actually some viewers have noticed
it true there's a railing and staircase
over by the band yeah that we have not
used at all on the show Matic yeah they
you know look the designers are amazing
they designed this thing it's beautiful
looking but we never ever have used it
once we have no idea why it's even there
okay and so tonight we thought let's
finally put these stairs to use let's
use them for the first time so first
we're going to use the show's
seven-year-old boy Justin to run up the
stairs and go to bed come on out here
Justin
[Music]
hey Justin Justin it's it's a school
night all right you've been running
around you've been acting crazy I want
you to get upstairs
right now young man and I want you to
get to bed okay please upstairs and
first of all kiss your mother goodnight
please up you go come on Justin let's
[Applause]
write oh and Justin say good night to
the audience okay good night
you know when you first said that the
kid the show should have a
seven-year-old boy I thought it might
seem a little on inappropriate but now
that he's here I think it's great thanks
you just made this sketch really creepy
for him
well I've earned my check yeah you know
I think we've got another use for the
stairs right now I think it's a perfect
location for wedding photos so right now
let's bring out the bridal party from a
Korean wedding
[Music]
very nice they look lovely don't they
very nice
alright give the ladies a hand she's
getting married you look beautiful
bye bye and look I wasn't even in a
sketch
he's just stepped out of the crowd and
took a photo now we've cut now we've got
one last use for the stairs that we
think is perfect how about a traditional
swashbuckling sword fight let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought we made amazing use of the
stairs tonight it was thrilling we had a
great time and the most Justin young man
up to bed right now off to bed say good
night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]